earlier I mentioned it's important to
make sure that the content fits within
the viewport to prevent horizontal
scrolling you should use relative units
when specifying widths for elements to
prevent them from accidentally
overflowing the viewport keep in mind
CSS does allow content to overflow its
container so if you don't specify a side
and say for example the image is bigger
than the container it will overflow you
can save yourself some headache and
prevent this from happening by setting a
max width of 100% in fact I recommend
adding a catch-all in your main CSS for
image embed object and video elements
that sets this just to be safe